alors au travers de votre propos je vois
que vous n'aviez pas lu le programme du
candidat emmanuel macron puisque cette
mesure y figurer
[Musique]
alors du coup je vais peut-être sans la
re développer vous redonner les grandes
lignes de la politique que mon
gouvernement entend mener ses grandes
lignes c'est d'abord de répondre à
l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
bataille du plein emploi c'est accélérer
la transition écologique et sortir des
énergies fossiles c'est promouvoir
l'égalité des chances et assurer la
sécurité des français c'est conforter
notre souveraineté industrielle
stratégique
alimentaire et ma méthode c'est bien sûr
d'écouté et de respecter chacun pas
d'être d'accord avec chacun alors vous
le savez j'ai reçu tous les groupes
parlementaires pour des consultations
tous car vous avez tous été élus par les
français mais au cours de notre
rencontre madame le pen je crois qu'on
peut le dire il n'y a pas vraiment eu de
convergence et après ma déclaration de
politique générale
je vous écoutez madame le pen et je vous
le confirme je n'irai pas chercher les
voies du rassemblement national
et je le dis hier madame la présidente
le pen ceux qui n'ont pas voté la
censure n'exprimer ni une confiance au
gouvernement d'une participation à la
majorité car madame le pen il y aura
toujours quelque chose qui s'interposera
entre nous cela s'appelle les valeurs
il y a une chose dont je suis certaine
comme première ministre et comme femme
engagée depuis des années au service des
françaises et des français c'est que mon
adn ma colonne vertébrale s'appelle la
république
alors oui je vous le redis madame le pen
mon identité c'est la liberté c'est
l'égalité c'est la fraternité c'est la
laïcité et
et comme première ministre c'est autour
de ces valeurs que je veux rassembler et
uniquement autour d'elle et ses valeurs
madame le pen vous avez vous beau tenter
de vous les approprier je suis convaincu
que dans les faits vous ne partagez pas
[Applaudissements]